I've spent though asked a dozen years
thinking about,
uh,
what I consider to be one of the
fundamental challenges of leadership in
that is the challenge to notice critical
information in your environment.
There are so many interesting stories of
the new millennium of situations where
there were people who behaved
inappropriately and they get an awful
lot of attention in the headlines from
madoff to jp Morgan's recent problems to
Enron and across the hundreds of
scandals,
there are often some bad people doing
some bad things.
My focus is not on those individuals,
but the fact that in each of those cases
there are so many other people who
should have noticed something was wrong
and they didn't.
Um,
Warren Bennis,
the leadership scholar,
um,
talked about one of the characteristics
of an excellent leader as somebody who
is a first class no desser.
And my book on the power of noticing is
really an attempt to help MBA students,
executives to become firstclass noticers
so that they can be aware of problems,
challenges,
and opportunities that would allow them
to be more effective.
The truth is I don't consider myself to
be a particularly effective notice.
Sir.
I've been working on it a lot in the
last dozen years.
Um,
but I always took pride in my ability to
focus as opposed to my ability to
notice.
And some of us who focus very,
very effectively might want to think
about the question of whether they can
develop the skills of noticing to go
along with their skills of focusing.
A number of years ago,
um,
I had an opportunity to notice,
and I failed to do so.
And it's been an obsession with me ever
since.
On march 10 2005,
I was hired by the u s department of
Justice and a landmark case that they
were fighting against the tobacco
industry.
I was hired as a remedy witness.
That is,
I was hired to provide recommendations
to the court about what the penalty
would be if in fact the department of
Justice succeeded in its trial against
the tobacco industry.
I'd spend a couple of hundred hours
working for the Department of Justice,
including submitting my written direct
testimony,
which had been submitted to the court.
I was scheduled to be understand on May
4th where um,
the tobacco industry attorneys would be
asking you a series of questions on
April 30th a number of days before my
May 4th testimony,
I was in Washington dc to be to meet
with Department of Justice attorneys to
prepare for my time on the stand when
the day started,
the Department of Justice Attorney that
I had been working with said to me,
Professor Bays Herman,
this occurred long after he had learned
to call me Max.
You said Professor Bays,
the Department of Justice requests that
you amend your testimony to note that
the testimony would not be relevant if
any of the following four conditions
existed.
He then read to me for legal conditions
that I didn't understand when he was
done talking.
I said to him,
why would you ask me to amend my
testimony when you know that I didn't
understand what you just said to me?
And his response was because if you
don't agree,
there's a significant chance that senior
leadership in the Department of Justice
will remove you from the case before you
are on the stand on May 4th to which I
said,
okay,
I don't agree to those changes,
and his response was,
good.
Let's continue with your preparation.
I was jarred by the fact that something
very strange had occurred,
but I was overwhelmed in life.
I was trying to help this case and I
didn't quite know what had occurred,
but to this day I'm critical of the fact
that they took no action.
I did appear on trial on May 4th and the
trial ended in early June,
but on June 17th I woke up in a hotel
room in London.
I was working with another client at the
time and they woke up early at 5:00 AM
and I opened up the New York Times Web
web edition and I read a story about
Matt Myers,
the president of tobacco free kids who
had come forward to the media with
evidence about how Robert Mccallum,
the number two official in the
Department of Justice,
was involved in attempting to get him to
change his testimony.
And I then read basically the same
account that I had experienced back on
April 30th Matt Myers had the insight to
know that he should do something with
this information about what had occurred
in terms of the attempt to tamper with
his testimony.
And at that point it was straight
forward to come forward to the media to
speak to congressional representatives
about what happened.
And my own role received media attention
as well.
But to this day I'm still struck by the
fact that I didn't come forward on April
30th when in the back of my mind I knew
something had occurred.
The reason I tell you this story is
because I think a lot of our fail you
did notice happens when we're busy.
It happens when we don't know exactly
what's happened,
what's happening,
but I think it's our job as the
executives,
as leaders,
as professionals,
to act when we're pretty sure that
there's something wrong.
It's our job to notice and to not simply
be passive when we can't quite figure
out the evidence.
It's our job to to take steps to figure
out what's going on and to act on,
on critical information.
Yeah.